whoosh actually I should do the
turnaround but stir whoosh so now rogue
wanna start war story is out we have
seen it some of us have seen it probably
not all of it do you want to see my
spoiler free review fantastic I have
that the link is below go there check it
out have fun no spoilers there for you
however for this one this is some
spoiler talk that's a spoiler warning
for you I'm giving you this opportunity
to walk or check out the spoiler free
review the spoilers are coming you've
been warned so let's talk spoilers so
Rob what a Star Wars story is funny
because in my spoiler free review I said
it's the first hour or so it's a little
slow it's a little jarring leading up on
the second video you didn't bother me as
much probably because I had already seen
the movie and the characters and their
paths and where they end up where
they're going up on the second favorite
girls like oh it's those characters
again I know where they're going that's
nice to see them not to say it's always
smooth it's not always smooth which is
really funny it might reveal like every
review out there there's no such thing
as a perfect film let's just say that
right now it's just not so in every
movie I see there are negatives and I
address those negatives because people
should be braced for those and movies
and people's love for movies got into a
weird love/hate thing it's like a movies
either perfect or if it has flaws it
must suck now how can you say a movie is
that and it has flaws cuz that's a
made-up word I made it up it could be
whatever the [ __ ] I wanted to be there's
wrong one have flaws yeah did I mean
that the first time yeah is it better
the second times yeah don't be so
extreme this or that love and hates like
everything is some shade of in-between
so basically the first act ability the
movie starts out with no crawl could
have benefited for a crawl in which the
crawl would have just been that catalyst
book that leads up to rug wine but they
do do a good enough job where credit
comes down me scaling or so is generous
those dads like our there's been a
problem we need you back it doesn't want
to go back so right there you know
there's Dale inner so guy is a big hand
in the creation of the Death Star
they've hit a snag the guy needs to go
back with a gun to his head and thus he
does it really is the saagara thing I
had a problem with which I'm fine with
sagar era now in the second showing but
that weird mind squid thing that proves
my that things done let me just take it
out altogether you could have just had
sagar era captures this pilot and just
puts them in a cell to rot and then they
find him they're like oh hey you need to
come with us and then that's that it
would have been the same outcome if they
cut the mind squid thing out entirely
would not change the film at all then
again you do the same with Vader
and it wouldn't change the filter at all
did you know
it's the scene in a second mom I suppose
you just felt slow from my expectations
also it's hard to go into a Star Wars
movie without expectations you hear the
Death Star you're like oh we're gonna
say the Death Star Trek [ __ ] because
there's on the trailer a trek [ __ ] but
you shouldn't really think that because
the biggest thing the Death Star ever
did was wipe out Alderaan that's
certainly not gonna be in this movie
I do love when Johnny McKee arming
shoots the dude in the back I mean he
shoots a couple of stormtroopers other
stormtroopers like oh hey there's a dick
down there and the dude with the busted
arms like I can't crawl out of here with
my arm and the guy's like he's right and
I can't let him go alright calm down why
I just shoots him in the back I thought
that was really cool because you know
rebellion you're gonna have to make
calls like that we're building a squeaky
clean I'm sorry the original trilogy
lied to you I do like at a point you
said me Gavin for was Grail the audience
clapping we saw yeah before I was like
as really cool as a yam in four but then
you see Jimmy Smits is bail organa
I really thought that was great because
it really these new movies in this new
Canon is doing what it can to bridge the
gap between the two generations of Star
Wars fans there are people I know they
grew up on the prequels and they loved
the prequels because they grew up on
them and that's fantastic I'm glad you
have that and there are og Star Wars
fans were like I grew up with the
original trilogy the prequels are not
good and no matter what I want to say
about it alright Phantom Menace I have
fond memories of the Phantom and as I
have nostalgia racked up in the Phantom
Ennis because the build up of that which
it was a lot of fun the movie itself not
so great but the build up was fun
Revenge of the Sith I can enjoy for what
it is daga clones I can't quantify it's
just bad but seeing Jimmy Smith's really
was a bridging of the worlds oh he was
Organa in the prequels
now he's Organa and well I guess this is
technically a prequel it's a movie that
bridges to the new trilogy at that it's
just a good move he says he's going back
to Alderaan your
[Music]
let's talk about CGI talkers we got to
talk about CGI target peter cushing
grand moff tarkin is in this movie but
he is all CGI when I first saw him I was
like that is all CGI I mean I get why
they had to do it they did have to do it
because he's a big part of this he was a
big part of the Death Star why would he
not be a big part of this movie and
actually he's really cool upon the
second time viewing it I'm like I'm glad
I get to see Tarkin again because Tarkin
never really got a lot of shine Tarkin
was one of the two people Darth Vader
took orders from the original Star Wars
trilogy this dude is a big deal among
the hierarchy of the Empire along the
same team or now I get to see him do
more which really brings relevance to
critic and the stress that he's under
man he's got this project he needs to
get off the ground he needs to impress
the Emperor he has his boss breathing
down his neck
yes his boss's boss breathing down his
back yes his boss trying to take his
shine away and take credit all himself
and just I felt for the dude I really
did poor cranek or imperial dick but
when I first saw CGI target as much as I
was like that CGI Tarkin it's like the
CGI of him got better as the movie
progressed I don't know if my eyes were
just adjusting to the fact that there
were a couple lines especially that line
where he's like the plans to the Death
Star down there correct I was like that
looks just like Peter Cushing he's
talking that was the best CGI of him in
the movie for nothing else I want them
to devote every penny they have in
perfecting and refining CGI Tarkin for
the blu-ray release that is an
adjustment a tweak in CGI that I would
be fine with I've seen some reports of
people saying it's disrespectful to have
CGI chakra in this movie and it detracts
from Peter Cushing and it shits on him
and his memory I don't see it that way
personally because everything that
Tarkin did in this movie was very much
Tarkin like if ghosts were real I really
feel like if you could ask Peter Cushing
if it would be okay if they do this I
think he'd be like oh yeah it's
perfectly fine because that's very much
Tarpon and the character and it's in
line with everything and yeah great do
it I can't speak for him I just feel
like that's how it would go down if
Darth Vader was like [ __ ] Grand Moff
Tarkin in the ass well Grand Moff Tarkin
wore a gag ball I'd be like yeah that's
out of character that's disrespectful to
the memory and I don't think Peter
Cushing would sign off on that but that
doesn't happen everything that Grand
Moff talking does in this movie is very
much Grand Moff Tarkin but thought it
was great he says at a point you may
fire when ready doesn't get more talking
than that one of the things I love most
about this movie is like when jyn erso
sees the hologram of her father saying
hey Gen if you're out there if you're
watching this if you're alive and really
sorry what you must
think of me but Galen ursa was pretty
much like they had me designed this
thing and at a point they would no
longer like they don't need me to
complete this thing so I can either let
the Empire create the super death weapon
in which case you guys could never beat
it or I could play the part go along
with it be the main architect of the
empire Super death weapon and put a
fail-safe in there in which you guys can
destroy this thing it's a very small
failsafe it's so small the Empire will
never detect it but if you can get the
plans you can see it in which case the
biggest joke in the original trilogy
other than the Ewoks is a little exhaust
port that could just destroy this entire
Death Star we all thought would what the
hell this is stupid how could they
overlook that now it's purposely done
it's genius it's fantastic and now that
joke is no longer a joke it was done on
purpose I love that does put a problem
with the JJ Abrams thing no Starkiller
base really had the same thing it's like
there's one thing you take it out
destroys the entirety of this planet
that is Starkiller base because now we
know it was sabotage for the Death Star
what was it for circular base did the
architect of Starkiller base go turncoat
on them was he like oh no I have to do a
fail-safe to wipe out Starkiller base
that's saying anything use force awakens
I love the force awakens I'm just saying
that does pose a problem for the whole
concept they just don't make them like
they used to I do love the Easter I love
a lot of the subtle Easter eggs there
were some Easter eggs that were super on
the nose like when Bail Organa is like
I'm sending for that Jedi that helped me
in the Clone Wars I'll go send for him
well you'll need someone you trust he's
like I trust her with my life I do like
what it does in the sense that in the
original trilogy it looks like they just
conveniently came across the planet that
had obi-wan Kenobi in it of all the
planets in the galaxy they just ended up
there and Leia was like oh what are we
oh then god ret tattooing that's where
obi-wan is so now you know she is
purposely going to Tatooine and the
Empire got her ship but not before she
was like alright we're crawling crawling
crawling across the finish line just
made to get the droids out of here oh
thank god
oh think the force so it does stitch
that up but really what this movie does
it really does stitch up the loose ends
of the original Star Wars movie a new
help however there were some of those
Easter eggs like especially with Jimmy
Smits character where he might as well
have been like they know what I'm
talking about don't you audience however
the Easter eggs with the pilots if you I
imagine you noticed it for those of you
who didn't hear it is among the final
battle the last act of the movie when
Jin or so and the entirety of the rogue
one squadron are trying to get the plans
to the Death Star the x-wings come in
those x-wing pilots a lot of them were
the
pilots of the original Death Star raid
that was amazing I love that is it gold
later you're like wait you're like
you're gold later the pilots that did
the Death Star raid would be pilots that
fought in this battle also the
rebellions they're not big a name for a
I love the fact also like red five
someone's on his tail this poor red
fighters is a little nerdy look I did
look I'm not gonna be gets blown out
that's creating the position for a new
pilot to come in and be red five which
was Luke Skywalker k2s oh shoot and
stormtroopers he's like I'm shutting the
doors now I'm locking it goodbye
BAM and he gets shot and you see the
light in his eyes go out I was like oh
man that was rough that actually hit me
and then you know you're like these guys
are not getting out of this alive figure
and it would be the case but now you get
to see it happen another standout death
was Donnie Yen he always says I'm one
with the force the forces with me I'm on
with the force the forces with me and he
has to flip that switch there's a lot of
fire is pretty much c-3po has the force
now and we know that I'm one with the
force the forces with me I'm one with
the force the forces with me chanting
I'm one with the force forces with me
lasers going by him because he's like if
it all is as the force wills it if it's
the will of the force I will flip that
switch if it's the will of the force
that I get shot and die that's what's
gonna happen but rut dude Hail Mary
attempt
I gotta flip that thing he makes it and
he dies it was just a really touching
sad that that shield around the world
did make me laugh though I was like you
guys need to shut that shield down I got
the code for ya it's one two three four
five right which is an ironic circle
that space balls from Star Wars Star
Wars from space balls we're gonna talk
Darth Vader you want me let's talk Darth
Vader Darth Vader I love the fact that
he's sparingly in this movie he's not in
it a lot I didn't want him to be in it
alive we got an entire trilogy of Darth
Vader I wanted some other people to get
their shine and in the world of
progression prorating it really does
line up this one's Orson chronic and
grand moff tarkin with a little bit of
darth vader Crenna gets wiped out the
next one is Grand Moff Tarkin with Darth
Vader Grand Moff Tarkin gets wiped out
then it's Darth Vader then Darth Vader
in the effort you know there's a
progression of character here like it
does line up to make sense but even
Darth Vader's suit when you look at it
alright so the original Star Wars movie
his helmet was a little bigger his eye
pieces were red because it didn't have a
big budget so his eye pieces looked red
and his sit sash in the original Star
Wars movie a new hope is on the outside
of his shoulder piece and then in Empire
Strikes Back his sis - is on the inside
underneath his shoulder piece this
outfit Darth Vader's outfit in here
everything about it is straight up a new
hope Darth Vader outfit I
continuity like that man is just
fantastic and I love when Orson credit
goes to what is clearly Mustafar
invaders hanging out in what looks like
bear adore and then Vader's in his tank
which I love a vulnerable moment like
that with Darth Vader's reminded me of
Empire Strikes Back when his helmet gets
put on and that one dude see is the back
of his head you're like well that's a
vulnerable space that Vader's in right
now that I love that same thing but
Vader does not have a suit he is
floating in a tank but then that hooded
figure series like no Advaita critic is
here for you I'm like oh great we get
another Snoke Theory because who's that
guy however Vader comes out toxic Renick
and I love that because James Earl
Jones's voice alone does not make Vader
feel like Vader in Revenge of the
Sibbett where is Padme is she okay is
she alright I still I'm like you're
still Hayden Christensen which I get
because he was Hayden Christensen a
second ago I would he's not gonna change
so much in ten minutes but now when he
walks out this is straight-up Vader he's
a very commanding president source and
chronics to kind of stumbling on his
words like well you know I just want
credit for the Death Star and he starts
choking in Vader turns brown it's like
be careful not to choke on your
aspirations get it a spur Eddy I'm gonna
go back into my bath I was gonna like a
pun of funny
Vader's never really cracked a pun or a
funny so I prefer he didn't do that but
I love the fact that he just choked
chronic but if we're talking about Vader
let's talk about the same so the Death
Star plans have been beamed up the Death
Star has shot down onto this play this
just wiped out which is a nice bit of
irony not only does it wipe everyone out
but or socratic dies from his home up
and love me the poetry but the Death
Star plans are out there the rebels have
it they're going to running like alright
we got to get it to the ship we gotta
get into the princess the door doesn't
open all the way all the lights go out
and you're here and also BAM his
lightsaber comes on they all start
shooting him and he just deflect deflect
deflect deflect
slice raises the dude up to the ceiling
holds him here kills some other people
slices him on the ceiling and a half
everyone signed this dude at the door to
crack he's like help us Vader is just
charging in like a monster from my
nightmare this dude is like take a which
I love that it went from help us to take
it because at a point we say help us
help us please save our lives he's like
yeah we're not living through that this
dude's gonna murder us all so just take
the plans that
was a born dude takes the plans Vader
impales him through the door Vader
almost gets them they get out of there
they leave that is a stand out Vader
scenes we see why he is to be feared we
never really saw that in the original
Star Wars it wasn't too exciting that
fight in an Empire Strikes Back he
didn't want to murder Luke it's a very
personal thing where he just wants to
disable him and then recruit him then
return to the Jedi is a very personal
father-son battle moment among the two
of them so it's not really that
murderously intense this was this was
straight-up a murder it was a slaughter
not since the younglings has Darth Vader
had so much fun wasting humans you could
see it in his mask the smile in the
glint of his shaded eyes so maybe that
was me I loved it I was smiling the
entire time and then they get the plans
to Leia and she turns around she's CGI
Leia and they're like what is this and
she's like hope and then they bow and
they go to warp and then that's the end
of the movie and at that point the best
thing to complete the circle is you go
home right there you'll pop in a new
hope and that's where you are
Leia ship comes over the Star Destroyers
pelting it and there we it's ten minutes
later it really seamlessly flows it ties
right into it I've never seen that never
in Star Wars history have we seen a film
and right when the next one picks up
thought it was great it was really well
done it reminded me of a new hope and it
really does polish up a new hope the
problems that I had with the plot lines
and a new hope we're really stitched
together so that's it guys Death Star
plans Grand Moff Tarkin Darth Vader and
the murder of some rebels down a really
dark scary hallway so I know it being a
spoiler talk I didn't talk about
everything in rogue one to be expected
so I imagine there are things you wanted
to talk about that I didn't talk about
so whatever those are comment below let
me know start the conversation down
there and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]